hey youtubers is Charlie so by popular
request a lot of you were asking for a
sabot our identity video from the flash
last week so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen last week's episode there's
also Man of Steel to stuff going on if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do DC videos every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything there's a
flash ring giveaway that's going on
right now so I'll explain that stuff at
the end of the video but we got to talk
about who's avatar is there a couple big
theories that I'm going to explain and
I'll explain the Daniel West arcs from
the comics because Wally West is one of
those big theories not the best one
though I think there's more evidence for
another pic and then I'll explain the
Superman may enough steel to stuff if
you didn't know there will be another
Man of Steel movie that will have
nothing to do with Zack Snyder whether
you think that's crazy that's great
we'll talk about that in a second but
who is savat are there are three big
theories right now the biggest one that
I'll say and I don't think the best one
is Wally West just in the way that
Savitt are gave him his powers sort of
like he bootstrapped himself in a
version of the future flash storyline
from the comics no you there when I
become a wire hanger I caused Jenna get
your speech i granted you oh no i'm for
you to myself
only I can bring out my greatness so if
you don't know who the future flashes
that's actually Barry Allen from the new
52 from a timeline 20-plus years in the
future so he's become so full of Speed
Force that his costume looks blue he
emits blue lightning that's why people
call him the blue flash or the future
flash in avatar just seems like he has a
really personal connection to all the
characters especially Barry Allen this
season so it would make sense that
whoever he is he is somebody that we've
met or we're going to meet very soon the
reason why it's such a big twist is
because future flash Barry Allen comes
to the conclusion that all of his
friends have died so many terrible
things have happened to the people that
he loves because of what he's done he
feels like the way he's used his powers
have caused fractures in the Speed Force
so not only has he hurt the people he's
loved he's hurt the very source of his
powers so he wants to hit a hard reset
button like where's that giant red
button just make it all go back so it's
a bit of a twist on the flashpoint
storyline where he's like I'm going to
go back and I'm going to reverse the
death that happened only in this case
it's the death that did not happen and
either you love the idea or you hate it
but Barry comes back in time to kill
himself if I'm not alive to cause all
these problems then these problems won't
happen which is a terrible way to solve
the problem new 52 Wally West steps in
saves the situation because he gets his
power so it all ends up fine it wasn't
the greatest storyline but there were a
lot of really cool things that came out
of that especially the idea of this
crazy future version of Barry which
looked a lot like sabotage he emits a
blue energy from his suit it's way more
hardcore even though the aesthetics of
TV savat are more influenced by Mark
Waid era they're just like a little more
freakish looking he's made to look like
an actual monster which gets into Daniel
West storyline in the way his
reverse-flash costume looks so that is
also a bit of a Wally West story but
because of the changes during the new 52
Wally West was somebody else he wasn't
irises brother irises brother was a
person named Daniel West and he became
the new 52 version of the reverse-flash
because evil bars dawn wasn't around
typically when you're talking
about the reverse-flash in any
incarnation you're talking about eobard
thawne but they changed a bunch of stuff
for the new 52 daniel west became the
reverse-flash for that storyline it was
sort of like an air do well who was
getting into trouble his whole life he
had a bad family situation they had an
abusive father that he later put in a
wheelchair
they'd caused them to become estranged
from IRA so they had all this family
drama going on he eventually gets sent
to prison because he falls in with a
group like the Rogues he becomes a
criminal once he gets out he gets into
an accident that gives him speed force
powers in like all crazy unhinged people
when you get superpowers you don't turn
into a hero you turn into a super
villain so in his crazy Speed Force
addled mind he comes to the conclusion
that he's going to go back and change
what he did and kill his father so that
his sister iris will love him again and
everything will go back to normal but
it's a big WTF twist because going back
in time to kill someone just like the
blue future flash is a terrible idea so
eventually they stop him they throw him
in prison
but as the thing is is he gets more and
more powerful more full of speed force
he becomes more monstrous his costume
starts to reflect that so aesthetically
and thematically you have a lot of
Daniel West stuff going on in here even
though this is Mark Waid era characters
because Savitt are came during his era
in the comics you have Daniel West
costume and then the name drop of future
flash because saboteur keeps saying I am
the future flash a lot of people have
watched this with subtitles and they
claimed it's a comma comes here so if
that's true he's saying that he is the
future not the person the future flash
but there's a lot of liberal I winking
it's very ambiguous just because they
want you to wonder who he is so they're
mixing and matching a lot of comic-book
things so that's where a lot of the
Sabbat are wally west theories are
rooted but the big wrench in that plan
is iris West so assuming that there's no
trickery going on here there's no
Holograms they're not misleading us
she's actually dying in this moment
wally west would probably not kill his
sister under any circumstance like I
said they're borrowing from the Daniel
West storyline Daniel West loved his
sister iris in would do nothing to hurt
her but Savitt are has shown open
content for every single member of team
flash Barry Allen most of all so I think
there's better options for who's avatar
is there is evidence very strong
evidence to suggest that it's HR he
knows way too much about the Speed Force
that he hasn't revealed before the Speed
Force that's a really tricky dangerous
place how does he know that he knows
that speedsters exist because we saw the
earth 19 flash but they haven't said
anything about what they study on earth
19 have they been studying the Speed
Force how did he get all this
information he seems like he knows more
than Jay Garrick does about the Speed
Force so already very suspicious the
fact that he's so nice and saccharine is
a bit off-putting is just weird is like
nobody is that nice then there's a lot
of saboteurs dialog he says a lot of
things that are similar to things that
HR says so he says he loves a good myth
HR has been writing a story this whole
time making himself the hero they may
never tell you about fighting gun
there's nothing ever stays the same the
harder you work to take down the bad
guys the more they up their game
originally our team has a secret weapon
of its own
a man of science a man of action and
that man's name is H R well look who has
a vortex cannon Oh
well before my greatness be a tall as
you are the presence of your mic enough
you're just a man like me I'm nothing
like you very you're cruel you're
selfish from my perspective
you're the baby so he loves to be the
hero of his own story that's kind of how
avatar thinks of himself you don't have
to actually be a god you just have to
get people to believe it more damning
evidence he calls Wally Wallace the only
other person that calls him that is
sabotage invent he's also training Wally
to become faster in faster reverse-flash
style I know this seems kind of like a
repeat of the season one plot so that he
can open a portal to the Speed Force
so rewind a flashpoint saboteur gets the
bright idea that he can leave the Speed
Force because this is the future version
that Barry is trapped there he watches
Barry create flashpoint and says here's
an opportunity I'll use the fact that
Wally really wants to be a speedster
give him those powers back and then
trick him into releasing me or replacing
me in the Speed Force the big changes
they made from the comics is replacing
one another in the comics you can enter
the Speed Force you can leave this be
force it's not like there's a finite
mass that you have to replace if you
take something from it so that is
something that the TV show has to
explain in the next couple of episodes
maybe even in this next episode when
Barry goes into the Speed Force so he's
going to be facing all of his villains
we'll get a lot more information about
what's avatar was doing Wally was stuck
in there in for those of you that are
wondering about Eddie so that's kind of
like that third theory now because he
featured so prominently in this episode
while I would love to see Eddie is the
future villain on the show cobalt blue
style in what a coincidence avatars
lightening looks kind of blue even
though technically it's white I think if
they were going to make Eddie a villain
they would have announced him a while
ago and they would have made him a
bigger character in present day
typically the way the flash sets up big
twist is that it highlights them way
early on down the road like think about
what they did with Jay Garrick in hunter
zolomon we met him in the second episode
so the odds are that we met the person
that's going to become Savitt are
already we just don't know it yet but
let me know in the comments what your
biggest avatar theory
and while you guys are thinking about
that I'll explain the Man of Steel to
news so the big news is that Matthew
Vaughn might direct Man of Steel to now
he did x-men first class he did the
Kingsmen movie he's working on a sequel
for that right now
he's a great director he does great
characters he's arguably doing a better
job with the x-men movies by doing a
Kingsman movie that's a better x-men
movie than the last x-men movie so he's
in talks right now to direct they
haven't confirmed him yet they haven't
confirmed what the story is you know
Superman's a man of tomorrow or
something in that vein but the really
big thing is that this confirms the Zack
Snyder will not be directing the next
movie which I think we all felt like
what's going to happen anyway like the
current line of thought now is that the
Zack Snyder creative team will sort of
leave the DC Universe after Justice
League in all the other movies you see
going forward we'll take a little bit
from that just in the way the characters
look but they'll be doing their own
thing going forward so if you've been
waiting for Zack Snyder to leave the DC
EU that will happen sooner than you
probably thought so
I feel like Justice League will still be
a fine movie but going forward it is
going to be amazing Wonder Woman will be
great Aquaman is going to kick ass and I
can't wait to see what the rated-r Lobo
films that they're talking about it's
going to look like that's basically DC's
version of Wolverine so if you love
Logan you love Deadpool there's a good
chance that DC will do a rated-r version
of Lobo but I got new iron fist and I'm
going to post next then I'll post my
flash episode tomorrow
so it's all going to be great bunch of
comic-book stuff happening this week
while you wait for that click here to
get ready for next week's flash episode
and click here to rewatch that Wonder
Woman trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video
you